[Musique]
oh
comment est né le quartier de la noé on
en parle avec juan massenya qui a passé
sa jeunesse dans ce quartier et le maire
emblématique de chanteloup les vignes
bjerregaard où
[Musique]
on va on va raconter l'histoire 1 200
cloud absolument au bachelor a vu
d'ailleurs
de partager cet instant là avec avec
deux personnages dès que vous connaissez
bien sûr leur juan massenya vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes auteur vous êtes
grand spécialiste de musique notamment
en plus lu de plus y compris en plus
c'est où il avait grandi à chanteloup et
j'ai grandi à chanteloup et c'est à
chanteloup que j'ai en partie compris
que la musique ce serait certainement
une passerelle pour pour aller voir
ailleurs si j'y étais et donc en
mélodies
cette petite ligne de train qui faisait
mantes la jolie saint lazare nous a
permis comme ça d'aller découvrir le
reste de l'ile-de-france qui était déjà
énorme à l'époque les nomme héros c'est
quelqu'un que tu connais bien que tu m'
beaucoup et que tous bords alors ici
c'est une star absolue évidemment ça
vous le disiez déjà dans un documentaire
dont va vous voir des extraits qui
s'appelait beaulieu ça c'est pierre
cardo père car 12 a été le maire
emblématique de chanteau des vies nous a
été député vous êtes arrivé ici en 75 on
va en reparler
on va regarder peut-être d'abord grâce à
un extrait de votre documentaire qui à
quoi une dizaine d'années qui a oui un
peu plus d'une dizaine d'années
absolument qu est intemporel tiens mais
qui est intemporel qui s'appelle
banlieusards et vous raconter
d'histoires de chanteau on va voir un
premier accès qui nous rappelle parce
que c'était chanteloup avant que ce soit
ce que c'est aujourd'hui
jusque dans les années 60 chantre où
c'était un petit village bien
franchouillard peuplé depuis la nuit des
temps de familles d'agriculteurs des
maraîchers des paysans comme
tout va changer tout va basculer dans
les années 70 sachant trou parce que
l'état va décider de construire un
quartier tout neuf au milieu des champs
vous cité hlm de 8000 habitants au
milieu de nulle part
voilà c'était au milieu de nulle part ah
oui justement êtes-vous juanjo alias
juanito pour les intimes oui
vous avez grandi ici à chanteloup et
vous parliez de cette ambiance qui était
extrêmement joyeuse et festive est-ce
que c'est toujours le cas
je pense que chanteloup n'échappait pas
à l'air du temps c'est à dire qu'on est
dans les années 70
grande partie de la population sort de
la ruralité accède à la modernité
d'autres viennent de pays où quand on
parle de d'agriculture et de monde rural
là on est carrément dans une autre
époque et ici c'est l arche de noé donc
toutes ces populations avaient le
sentiment de
d'avoir la vie devant soi en fait
d'avoir le monde a apporté de deux
doigts et effectivement ça rendait
heureux et puis s'il ya un élément qui
avec le temps maintenant revient me
revient en mémoire c'est que les parents
étaient jeunes que les enfants était
petit et que le pays était encore
prometteur de beaucoup de choses on est
au milieu de début des années 70 ce
milieu des années 70 donc on est dans
une sorte d'insouciance et on n'a pas
encore ce terme les trente glorieuses où
la fin des trente glorieuses à l'oreille
mais le champ tout va être impactée par
cet apport des années 70 absolument
pierre cardo alors vous arrivez dans les
à chanteloup
vous étiez chez chrysler à poissy voilà
vous optez janvier parce que j'ai lu
votre votre livre l'espoir n'est pas un
luxe ou vous raconter tout ce cirque un
livre formidable parce que ça raconte et
votre histoire est l'histoire de
chanteloup et vous venez habiter ici oui
je cherchais un appartement j'avais
atterri d'abord dans un foyer sonacotra
au grésillons carrières sous poissy
parce que je pensais que c'était jeunes
travailleurs donc c'est pour moi enfin
je me suis rendu compte que ce n'était
pas tout à fait l'ambiance de la cité u
et donc dont j'avais entre temps on
avait un première l'aîné de notre
famille qui était né donc il fallait un
appartement plus grand et on a trouvé un
gainage des appartements superbe à des
prix très raisonnables
c'était ce qu'on appelle les irm à
l'époque et donc j'ai habité plusieurs
années dans dans cet appartement mais en
attendant ce qu'on n'a pas la cité de la
noé ça brise ça donc j'ai créé la
première association de locataires sur
le secteur et j'ai découvert une cité
mais lunaire pour moi gross était alors
la vie ici c'est d'abord
il y avait rien dans la cité rien
n'avait été prévu en fait le conflit qui
avait eu lieu entre la commune et l'état
sur cette construction qui n'était pas
souhaitée par les habitants ça s'était
traduit par un procès
qui avait été gagné par les associations
de change joue contre l'état et qui avec
donc le tribunal a considéré que le
permis quand ce n'étaient pas valables à
partir de là l'état a abandonné la ville
donc pas de commerce on savait même pas
où passer les réseaux c'est abandonner
complètement quoi ah oui il y avait une
zone industrielle qui étaient promises
il y avait la gare qui était toujours
pas là enfin il ré rien et donc pour
faire ses courses il fallait monter au
village pour acheter le minimum certains
traverser la pièce la plaine avec des
caddies pour aller faire les courses
chez leclerc à carrières sous poissy
enfin voila c'était tout et n'importe
quoi on avait des câbles téléphoniques
qui passaient électrique est passé d'une
fenêtre à l'autre d'une tour à l'autre
dans le béguinage voilà et et en plus
après va y avoir la sphère aranda avec
l'histoire dit alors ça c'est affaire de
corruption la wii mais va ça va rien
arranger
rien arranger ça va se passer très mal
donc l'état abandonne la ville à son
triste sort et comme en ce moment même
temps il ya nanterre dont on est en
train de raser les bidonvilles barbès
pigalle dont on est en train de
restructurer les quartiers tous ces
populations dont paris se débarrasse et
expédié h 30 où il ya de la place 1 au
départ c'était prévu pour les ouvriers
de l'industrie automobile ont dépassé
servirions groupe mais elle veut jouer
chrysler va à poissy yahia renault flins
ou et au bol est en fait il rien elle
avoue sans patronale donc c'est pas des
ouvriers qu'on va récupérer mais des
chômeurs oui c'est sacré sans grande
difficulté mélangé à des cadres qui sont
venus pour un cadre de vie qui avait
l'air assez agréable donc évidemment au
fur et à mesure pas de service des
populations qui n'ont pas tout à fait
l'habitude de cohabiter ça va se
traduire par plusieurs communautés
différentes envoyé à combien
3,63 communauté on va passer deux mille
habitants à 11000 en peu de temps et on
va avoir une naissance par jour alizée
incroyable donc on est un pays en voie
de développement et peut-être on n'a pas
d'argent peut-être qu'on peut rêver d un
petit peu on n'a rien sur la conception
même de deux sets de 7 6 t2 et un grand
architecte et mila lyoen
qui voilà qui missionnée par l'état et
il ya un petit nez un extrait dans votre
documentaire roanne qui est absolument
saisissant ce dire il raconte ce qu'il a
fait il ya un côté mégalomane incroyable
on regarde en action une action
de l'affectivité
d'enval derrière
lui d'en construire sans logement
des hlm n'a pas grand intérêt
un grand sourire 3000 devient d'un
univers que l'on manipulé l'enfant de ce
fait sa une toute autre dimension
ça devient une façon de manipuler un
devenir déjà incroyable mais vous parlez
mais là vous parlez de côté mais
mégalomane mais je trouve que ce qu'il
exprime justement est intéressant dans
tout ce débat conquis qui existent sur
la question des banlieues la manière
dont ça a été fait ça a été pensé
justement et vous qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire aujourd'hui vous qui avait été
maire de cette ville pendant pendant
longtemps
le discours de l'architecte ah oui parce
que c'est je pense que il enfin il se
fait une idée un peu trop forte sur le
rôle que va jouer l'urbanisme sur le
comportement des gens le problème c'est
à vous gagnez vous qu'on vous êtes
convaincu de sa alors lui il est
convaincu qui va jouer un rôle important
sur la façon dont ça va moi je partage
son avis et bien moi je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de responsabiliser
systématiquement les architectes sur ce
qui se passe bien sûr il ya des erreurs
de conception notamment fermé les places
là c'est une place permet un glacier
ouais ça fait qu'il ya un isolement de
la place qui fait que les gamins ne
savent même pas ce que c'est que la plus
grosse est une société dont on ne sont
pas loin quand on va s'aventurer quand
on va nous proposer quand borloo va
proposer le grand projet de ville et
qu'on va enfin pouvoir modifier
l'architecturé après avoir entendu ce
que disaient les habitants et les
différents acteurs la police et on va
restructurer et on va ouvrir les places
on va ouvrir à la circulation on va
éviter cet effet d'enfermement c'est ce
que demain les habitants et toute la
restructuration va être basé là dessus
on va pas détruire pour détruire et pour
réduire le nombre georges sociaux ont
détruit pour ouvrir et aérée et c'est ce
qu'on va faire donc moi quand on
explique que c'est l'urbanisme qui
responsables non la façon dont on a
projeté cette population la façon dont
on a pas autour de l'urbanisme prévu
comment on allait se comporter sur le
plan humain qu'est-ce qu'on allait avoir
comme activité quels étaient les moyens
du fonctionnement là ça a été la
catastrophe quand je suis arrivé j'avais
aucun pouvoir tout était décidé à me
place le budget les gens que la ville
n'avait plus le droit de décider de son
but et viendront de dépenses
voilà donc on avait plus de pouvoir
c'est la chambre régionale des comptes
qui décidez et donc il fallait reprendre
le pouvoir pour essayer d'imprimer une
volonté locale pour transformer les
choses je ne veux pas qu'on accuse
uniquement les architectes il on nous
annonce habilité moi je trouve qu'il ya
mille ans mais quand même changer la vie
des gens mais je me méfie toujours des
gens qui veulent
bien sûr quand on a amélioré chanteloup
au niveau de l'organisme on a amélioré
l'image on a amélioré le fonctionnement
en améliorer le quotidien des gens par
un urbaniste qui était une carte de
visite présentée sur l'extérieur
notamment qu' elle est revalorisée donc
c'est important l'environnement la façon
dont on est perçu en tant que ville bon
mais en même temps on peut pas se
contenter de réhabiliter le béton pour
dire ça va aller mieux l'humain c'est
l'essentiel si ça s'est dégradé en moins
de dix ans il a fallu commencer les
premières habitations à chanteloup vous
rendez compte au bout de huit ans on
propose une réhabilitation moi ça
faisait je venais d'être élu
j'ai dit mais c'est pas possible
enfin
ça s'est pas dégradée tout seul c'est
bien que fortement des habitants c'est
qu'il ya un malaise qu'il faut qu'on
traite c'est pas uniquement en traitant
le béton qu'on va régler le problème il
faut donc s'occuper de l'humain il faut
redonner une âme à cette ville il faut
redonner de l'espoir il faut donner des
repères aux gamins fait voilà c'est là
dessus cependant c'est la politique de
la ville ça la vraie vous en apercevez
de ce malaise là que vous avez grandi
ici
non pas du tout parce que
on vient d'aborder la notion d' espace
et en fonction des âges les le même
espace ne n'impacte pas votre quotidien
de la même façon serrée quand vous êtes
gamin vous allez de l'école primaire
chez vous dans l'absolu les distances
elles sont réduites à l'est maximum 1 km
c'est vrai qu'au fur et à mesure
que le temps passe et
on a commencé à ressentir cet effet
d'enfermement n'ont pas de notre fait
mais du regard des autres est ce que
disait pierre cardo est tout à fait
juste c'est à dire que le regard sur les
habitants étaient pratiquement
inexistant voire même les desiderata les
origines les parcours les histoires de
ses habitants étaient des paramètres qui
était très peu pris en compte et il a
fallu un moment qu'on humanis et
quartier parce que le problème du bâti
c'est que s'il n'est pas humaniser ça
devient uniquement de l'asphalt du béton
et des parpaings et une ville quand on a
la prétention parce qu'une ville c'est
un magma social c'est un magma humain
avec des histoires des parcours quand on
a la prétention de vouloir faire vivre
60 plus de 60 ethnies différentes
ensemble la priorité c'est l'humain et
emile aillaud ce qu'il dit et je suis
tout à fait d'accord il
faut faire très attention procès
d'intention ce qui concerne ceux en
responsabilité du bâti parce que ça a
été la politique de notre pays pendant
les trente glorieuses et on a oublié que
bayal et des gens qui allaient habiter
avec des algorithmes humains organiques
etc et si on ne trouvait pas la note
juste pour les faire vivre ensemble peu
importe le bâti en fait on s'est rendu
compte à champions on a très vite
compris que la question du bâtiment
c'était secondaire n'était pas là ce
quand bien même c'est ce que disait
souvent pierre canton je me suis là même
borloo disait saint quand on aime quand
on n'aime pas sa ville quand on n'aime
pas son pays quand on n'aime pas sa rue
son bâtiment on ne s'aime pas et alors
là tous les problèmes commencent et
c'est là qu'on a vu moi j'ai vu au fur
et à mesure parce que je venais en plus
d'une heure d'une cité de emmaüs donc là
on est dans des cités construites après
guerre quand on est arrivé à chanteloup
pour nous c'était l'avenir c'était ma
main était la promesse était magnifique
à voir une gare au pied avoir des des
commerces avoir cette espèce d'arche de
noé
il y avait quelque chose d'idyllique là
dedans malheureusement le projet s'est
arrêtée à mi chemin et surtout c'est
qu'on n'a pas
pris le temps d'essayer d'écouter les
gens qui venaient des quatre coins du
monde et qui habitait dans cette arche
de noé donc c'était ça le vrai problème
c'est pas les pour moi c'est pas les
architectes pierre cardo vous avez donc
vous habitez lavaud président et des
associations dont elle avait qu'un seul
associations éducatives et puis on vous
demande de vous présenter sur une liste
et puis je vous devenez mais qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé quand même à devenir
moi c'est toujours une question que je
me pose parce que il ya un tel boulot à
faire
j'ai peut-être peut-être de des moments
de désespoir fort qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui pousse quelqu'un vous lui à se dire
baverez j'y vais c'est à dire que
d'abord j'ai vécu mai 68 en arrivant
d'algérie surtout à lakanal pendant deux
ans lycées occupés je comprenais rien à
ce qui se passe et moi j'arrivais de
mars ces gamins qui connaissait pas la
société qui voulait la réforme et je me
disais mais qu'est ce qui se passe je ne
comprends pas comment on peut réformer
une société quand on ne la connaît pas
et donc je suis persuadé après 70 je
suis pas fait pour la politique c'est
vrai maintenant un monde qui m'échappe
il ya des gens qui ont des convictions
enfin ce que je prends pour des
convictions en réalité ce sont des
idéologies et je me dis non c'est pas
pour moi et puis le monde associatif à
chanteloup je vais m'impliquer très vite
et il ya des pouvoirs le terrain de foot
où il ya des gens qui sont entraînés il
ya une personne avec des bottes une
femme qui les entraîne légale un an
blues enfin voilà il n'y a pas de moyen
de transport aérien je vais faire du
foot j'ai jamais joué au foot
pratiquement moi je faisais que de
l'athlétisme et des sports de combat
donc je vais leur faire faire du sport
je vais m'en occuper je me retrouvais
président des locataires je vais régler
les problèmes de chauffage enfin bon et
tout ça petit à petit je me retrouve
président d'une association de gauche
alors qu'en réalité je suis à gauche
chaque joueur savait rien fait et et il
me demande de me présenter contre leurs
propres amis au conseil municipal en
plus ou d'un moment donc si vous voulez
c'est le paradoxe entre louvain et c'est
que ici là l'implantation locale elle
est essentielle et donc sans fait je
vais être poussés par les gens pour me
présenter alors j'ai pas envie je refuse
même au départ dominé et au bout d'un
moment tous les billets la rue mais
loyal et soyez les rapaces et toi qui
sera responsable de ce qui se passera
les associations j'ai pas envie que ça
disparaisse dans un truc plus ou moins
mal mal et voilà et j'y vais mais je
pense que je vais perdre parce que la
gauche vient de gagner à plus de 60%
même moins d'un an avant donc voilà pour
déjà pour tous et des candidats
s'étaient tous n'hésitez pas facile oui
je vous constituer la liste là le
dernier j'ai fait signer dans sa
baignoire quelques heures avant la fin
de la lola
et et on gagne et là je me dis mais vous
c'est que je suis encore une fois est ce
que j'ai fait et quand je prends
l'association déjà il ya des briques de
dettes le comptable foot et les factures
à la poubelle depuis six mois je
remonterai avec les huissiers mois enfin
voilà chaque fois j'ai pris un truc il
s'est passé des choses
extraordinaires bon là
j'ai été chargé d'une mission je peux
pas y échapper donc j'ai la population
qui m'a fait confiance je suis obligé
d'aller au turbin c'est tout et en même
temps pas de question et c'est de
l'inconscience peut-être je sais pas ce
qui m'attend mais je m'en fous il faut
que je fasse à donner une responsabilité
vous y allez quoi et comment je vais
faire j'en sais rien et vous avez
justement beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
on al'impression d'ailleurs que vous
vous arrêtez jamais et mais quand vous
mettez une rustine par là on a
l'impression que ça fuit pas par ici oui
s'il n'avait pas eu des moments de
désespoir vous aviez lu on vit tout
lâcher les moments de colère des moments
de oui mais il ya cette injustice si
vous voulez pour moi chant tous été
victimes d'une injustice et donc le fait
que cette ville soit victime d'une
injustice et que sa population subit ses
conséquences pour moi c'est essentiel
c'est ce qui va me permettre de dépasser
ces moments de désespoir parce que tu en
entends j'ai envie de balancer tout le
monde par la fenêtre les dossiers enfin
bon mais on se reprend très vite parce
que a patiemment où vous avez
l'impression vous avez une mission par
rapport à une forme d'injustice ça vous
donne des fleurs c'est incroyable c'est
peut-être un peu d'inconscience ne sait
pas toujours du courage faut pas croire
mais on sait pas ce qui nous attend
heureusement il faut jamais essayé de
savoir l'avenir donc vous foncez vous
posez pas de questions et vous faites et
à partir du moment où vous avez comme ça
a été même la chance que j'ai eue vous
êtes soutenus par la population par le
tissu associatif que vous avez réussi à
réunir des tendances qui n'était pas
fait pour s'entendre
vous êtes porté par une force qui va
vous faire
au bout d'un moment vous allez surmonter
tous les obstacles alors effectivement
ça peut être régulièrement des émeutes
oui mais comment on fait la passe est
portée que dans la population vous y
allez vous avez fait vous l'avez dit
vous avez fait des sports de combat
non
vous apprenez à vous maîtriser et moi je
parlais pas assez du essentiel c'est que
le respect ça se mérite ça prend du
temps mais un moment donné à force de
respecter les gens et de leur montrer le
respect que vous finissez par leur
inspiré du respect et sa fibre il ya
toujours une minorité qui une minorité
qui ne répondent pas cela mais la très
grande majorité va vous soutenir et dans
tous les problèmes qu'on a eus c'est
toujours la population et les
associations qui m'ont permis de
surmonter les obstacles et ça ça vaut
tous les encouragements il ya une chose
est sûre qui est fait est fait pour que
ton compte au lit votre lit un peu quand
on regarde ce que vous avez fait ici
parliez tout à l'heure d'idéologie en
disant moi j'étais pas un idéologue ce
qui est frappant c'est justement votre
empirisme se dire que vous regardez pas
les gens parce qu'ils viennent dit si
bien de là vous regardez leur situation
moi j'ai une formation gestion et puis
des tendances à l'abc je suis très fin
instinctivement je suis très porté sur
la psychologie j'ai eu des formations
dans ce domaine aussi mais je pars du
principe qu'on ne sait pas quelle est la
réponse tous styles et tous les rapports
des différentes inspections générales de
l'administration qui a été lancée sur
change ou disait cette ville elle est
ingérable et il faudra au moins 25 ans
pour ce qu'elle s'en sorte et ses
patients
donc à partir de là vous savez que les
réponses traditionnelles ne vont pas
fonctionné
j'avais une force qui était lié aux de
terrain donc j'ai utilisé à fond cette
richesse de la population alors j'avais
des projets sans arrêt des fois il y en
a qu'on capoter mais je veux dire il
faut laisser l'initiative aux gens le
vrai partenariat la vraie
co-construction c'est pas
un truc très structuré il faut laisser
l'imagination au pouvoir et il faut
accompagner les différents projets des
populations on en a eu des projets mamy
blue babilou enfin chantelauze est enfin
c'est parti dans tous les sens
c'était le bazar de l'hôtel de ville
comme lille mais ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne parce qu'il y avait de
l'émulation donc les gens étaient
motivés des projets dont il y avait un
projet collectif où il y avait ce
sentiment d'appartenance à une
communauté quelle et chanteloup il
s'entête pas tous français sentait pas
tous pour républicain sentaient
peut-être pas tous sais pas quoi il
s'était chantelouve et un point
d'ailleurs que les bagarres entre les
villes j'étais un peu emmerdé je me
disais [__] j'ai développé un peu trop
l'esprit de clocher sont en train de se
[__] sur la figure pour défendre le
territoire mais bon voilà c'est c'est
cette force de terrain je pense
qu'aujourd'hui et je regrette un peu la
façon dont la société s'est structuré
depuis quelques années avec de très
grosses intercommunalités en reléguant
un peu le maire au second plan alors que
le maire est un maillon essentiel pour
le fonctionnement humain de cette
société on a besoin d'humanité qui mieux
que le maire peut le faire et moi je
n'ai jamais considéré que le maire chef
de la police municipale bien armés c'est
le rôle qui doit tenir non moi c'est le
principal acteur le seul qui peut
maintenir le dialogue et quelle que soit
la situation c'est son devoir et c'est
ça sa noble mission il va falloir qu'on
y revienne un jour sinon ça va aller
très mal dans notre société parce qu'on
va avoir des antagonismes ceux des
grandes villes qui nous expliquent
qu'ils sont très contents d'avoir une
police municipale armée pour moi en
france il doit y avoir une police
nationale avec le maire qui a un pouvoir
de coordination des différents acteurs
sur le terrain c'est comme ça que ça
devrait fonctionner non pas
l'organisation un peu hirsute qu'on
observait de vie si le maire a
l'impression que c'est lui qui se fait
engueuler mais c'est pas lui quel
pouvoir ça ça va pas donc je pour moi le
maître lemaire chef d'orchestre n'est
pas patron de tout le monde mais qui
essaye de mettre les gens en relation
parce que vous avez beaucoup de gens sur
le terrain à chanteloup qui connaissent
pas les autres acteurs le policier ne
sais pas ce que fait l'éducateur
l'enseignant ne sais pas quel des
éducateurs spécialisés la pjj n'informe
pas les gens des mesures qu'elle prend
et donc à un moment donné faut une
coordination et si lui c'est le maire
qui est le mieux placé au milieu de tous
ces acteurs
une connaissance multiples des choses et
j'ai eu cette chance de pouvoir jouer ce
rôle et heureusement d'ailleurs par
rapport à ce que mon voisin me chambrent
un peu sur l'urbanisme parce que j'y
crois pas mais je trouve c'est trop
facile de responsabiliser je comprends
lui et de diass et à la juste la ferme
elle a un rôle à jouer la juve quand on
a réhabilité changer l'image avec ce qui
se fait aujourd'hui aussi mais
heureusement que j'ai confié catherine
arnould meyrinois l'actuel
parce que moi l'urbanisme j'avais pas
une opinion très positive et donc
heureusement que c'est elle qui a pris
en main et parce qu'on a détruit 10 le
beau jardin reconstruire mais le vous
savez très bien que quand même le le
l'environnement un envoi énorme dans la
psychologie des gens vous avez tant la
douleur manière d'évoluer je n'ai
kandolo m'a donné
gpv c'est quoi c'est un projet dit
j'ai les moyens de faire un truc énorme
pour chanteloup et en fait j'y crois pas
trop à l'urbanisme donc comment je vais
faire donc j'ai cherché la ligne rouge
qu'est-ce qu'elle file j'allais le fil
rouge que j'allais sur et c'était
l'aération de la cité parce que là il y
avait un enjeu on s'est basé là dessus
et puis bon heureusement cadeaux j'en ai
a pas que moi qui décide en mairie je
pense que les adjoints heureusement
qu'ils jouent et à l'époque
on a à la fois misé sur cette
revalorisation de l'habitat qui
revaloriser l'image que les gens à
visiter deux avaient d'eux mêmes et qui
à revaloriser l'image de chantoux
vis-à-vis des communes autour ce qui a
permis l'intercommunalité qui sinon le
petit mouton noir ne serait jamais
mariée avec personne et puis il ya tout
ce qu'a fait borloo en créant la
réussite éducative etc où on appuie à
fond là dessus on a créé des structures
pour permettre aux gamins d'avoir ses
repères dont ils avaient besoin pour se
comporter un peu mieux dans cette ville
et puis de l'espoir voilà et l'humain
c'est important parce que si on ne reste
pas c'est là dessus que vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup de jouer j'ai
l'impression quand on vous et c'est
parce que sinon comme disait roanne ils
vont détruire leur environnement s'il
leur plaît pas un don quand cela vous
avez raison mais moi quand on démarche
en tête
et l'humain hocine qui sont responsables
et ou non c'est trop facile pour les
politiques de se dégager de sa vie du
chaînon ron un moment assez le ciment
zilina tout vous nous disiez à un moment
je passais plus de temps enterré des
potes qui étaient morts d'accidents de
voiture d'ouvrir 12 que de codalet des
fêtes de mariage ya eu un moment quand
même un peu dû aux années de sorties
vous grâce à la musique notamment
il ya eu un moment des moments durs
quand même alors il ya eu des moments
qui était en écho avec ce qui se passe
est un petit peu partout dans ces grands
ensembles c'est à dire que il ya une
génération qui s'est retrouvé un peu
c'est ce que disait pierre
pas face à face à la réalité et personne
n'était préparé c'est à dire que quand
vous avez des populations qui viennent
des quatre coins du monde le rapport à
la drogue le rapport au chômage ce sont
des notions qui sont nouvelles ce que
quand on vient du fin fond du kurdistan
ou du de la casamance ou convient de de
la ruralité d'outre-mer ou ou du vietnam
du cambodge enfin toutes ces populations
c'était des populations qui n'avait pas
pour habitude de gérer ce type de
problème puisque bas au pays on vit
autrement au pays.le la famille le
village surveille les petits l'un on
était totalement libre oui les enfants
totalement c'était moi les souvenirs que
j'en ai ren tant qu'enfant bien
évidemment en plus on est dans une
période historique de transition c'est
un sentiment de liberté totale qui
venait bien évidemment de la
construction parler du sud 2 de
l'environnement la ville la façon dont
elles étaient construits et du nombre
d'enfants si le rapport enfants adultes
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un rapport de
jean marie petitclerc je crois qu'il
disait qu' il y avait à peu près 7 à
8000 enfants de moins de 10 ans quelque
chose comme ça enfin y avait une
quantité de gamin donc pour moi je
voyais dans mon quotidien je ne voyais
que des enfants
j'étais très rarement contact avec des
adultes puisqu'il partait le matin bossé
est rentré le soin et on avait cette
ville pour nous la ville nous appartient
d'apporter la journée donc oui c'est
vrai que arrivé au milieu des années 80
donc on a une période quand même qui est
impactée un petit peu tous les grands
ensembles qui était la période de la
drogue dure plus
l'émergence comme ça de cette 1ère
pandémie pour ma génération qui était le
sida plus la double peine ce qu'on
appelle la double peine chez nous c'est
à dire que battu fait deux trois bêtises
en bloc au pays ce qui fait qu'à chaque
rentrée scolaire bas y'avait où il
manquait un pote pas ce qui est le père
pendant les vacances avaient pris le
passeport et avait pris l'avion parce
qu'il faisait trop de bêtises ici il
avait confié à des oncles ou parce qu'on
arrivait 1 h 14 ans où je fais de la
moto sans casque ont fait un petit tour
de bagnols donc voila c'était une
période assez accident accidentogènes
mais pour autant avec le recul je dirais
que on pensait que c'était normal il
pensait que c'était normal tout ça on
pensait que ça faisait partie de la vie
on se rendait pas vraiment compte que ce
n'est pas normal aujourd'hui on peut se
peut le dire mais faty meziane michel
autres michel voilà il ya toute une
liste d'ailleurs le cimetière me
rappelle régulièrement à ses bons
souvenirs il ya toute une liste alors il
était un peu plus âgés que moi il avait
trois quatre ans de plus que moi mais
voilà tu en entends des 100 mur on
entend déjà à poissy on attendait
s'invente donc ce n'était pas quelque
chose qui était propre un socle à
chanteloup c'était générationnel on a
pris conscience d'ailleurs il suffit de
voir les images d'archivés qu'à un
moment
on est un peu à 8 10 ans est livré à
soi-même il ya un sentiment de liberté
entre 14 et 18 il ya le monde de
l'emploi games nous tend pas la main
faut aller à l'armée aussi cette
question là enfin bref on a été impacté
très rapidement par des questions un
petit peu trop sérieuse pour nous qu'on
n'était pas à même de pouvoir
résoudre voire même comprendre et
l'avait justement vous avez souligné
quelque chose à l'heure vous parliez de
de cet environnement que dans lequel
vous vivez on va parler là que la
question de l'image des quartiers et
quand on vient de chanteloup et quand on
évolue donc dans d'autres environnements
est ce que c'est une image qui nous
colle à la peau ou pas
je te dirais que c est à double
tranchant c'est à dire ça dépend où on
se place si c'est une rivalité entre
villes de chanteloup ça sert
ah oui parce que ça dépend du degré d'
analyse mme alliot marie alors environ
déjà trouvé du boulot dans notre
environnement proche c'était compliqué
puisque les deux perspectives d'avenir
c'était peugeot à poissy où renault à
flins homero donc dans notre esprit même
il ya un truc qui moi me
m'interpelle c'est que même la question
de l'emploi on ne se la posait pas
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir parce que le
système éducatif de l'époque l'école ben
il y avait un petit fascicule avec tous
les métiers proposés et puis de la page
4 à la page 6 c'était ce qu'on nous
proposait fallait pas aller au-delà donc
architectes médecins etc ça c'était
vraiment les plus opiniâtres et ceux qui
avaient un environnement familial ohler
jay tiens tu pourrais faire sciences po
les mains moi j'ai découvert ces mots là
j'avais 20 ans ouais donc un peu tard
c'est un peu tard donc c'est vrai que
aide de chanteloup certaine fierté parce
que pierre avait tout fait pour
justement qu'ils soient fiers de notre
île oui mais comptait d'ailleurs quand
tu vois là mais quand on arrive ailleurs
alors il ya des subterfuges gens ont dit
que l'on vient d'andrésy on vient de
poids si on vient de triel on vient
d'acter rares étaient ceux qui passaient
d'un monde à un autre on étaient
quelques-uns et par contre chanteloup
permettait une chose c'est que très
rapidement quant à lier tu savais qu'il
fallait être capable de parler toutes
les langues être capable
d'analyser les lyonnais très rapidement
parce qu'on passait régulièrement en
quelques minutes de cars ou en deux
stations et de bd terrain on passer d'un
monde à un autre donc on avait cette
capacité
sada certains d'entre nous voilà
l'adaptabilité c'est l'implication à
chantepie c'est davantage des quartiers
absolument sept cas parce qu'on connaît
les autres et les autres ne nous
connaissent pas alors est d'après vous
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait justement faire
pour que pour changer cette image et
cette perception que les autres peuvent
avoir justement des gens qui viennent de
ces environnements
très sincèrement je pense que ce sont
des des combats perdus d'avancé dans le
sens où ça prend énormément d'énergie et
ça génère le tout ce qu'il faut
c'est la perception que j'ai il faut
faire les choses il faut que l'on parle
de ce qui se et donnons pas de qui les
faucons par deux arrêtés de douala d'où
venaient seulement je suis parti
dernièrement ce départ et de vias à quoi
exactement j'étais en seine-saint-denis
j'habitais un porte de pantin et un jour
je vais aux impôts et je vois les tâches
d'en-dessous crèche baby loup
et je me suis dit voilà c'est un ces
championnats ça c'est la crèche baby
loup de chanteloup à la avoir réussi
comme ça à travers un laboratoire social
des expérimentations parce que ben
pierre tu t'es souvent casser la gueule
et puis tu as souvent réussi on ne se
souvient que les réussites toujours
relevé volé il ya un élément sur lequel
voudrait revenir qui est très important
c'est ce dynamisme entre la population
et les élus parce qu a pas d'enjeux de
pouvoir un champ clos donc quand les
élus alors il ya toujours une petite
minorité évidemment qu'ils voient les
choses à travers des lunettes pas très
valeureux valorisante mais le fait qu'un
élu fasse partie de la population ouais
et que la population ait son mot à dire
ça change tout ça change tout c'est à
dire qu'il ya plus dangereuse c'est ce
qu'avait bien regardez là on relève le
maire quand il tombe et quand tu tombes
le maire relève parce que c'est la même
bande puisque vous parliez de baby loup
c'est vrai c'est devenu la crèche baby
loup c'est devenu une star regardez tout
le monde on va regarder un extrait dans
vos religieuse à un extrait de
l'émission de drucker même drucker et
quelqu'un d'autre on parle cette crèche
chapelle la crèche baby loup c'est une
crèche modèle c'est une crèche
associative pas une crèche publique
c'est une crèche pas comme les autres si
elle est ouverte sept jours sur sept 24
ans aurait nui des jours
et cette tâche est dévolue par pierre
cardo député maire de gentioux jean paul
ovine c'est pour ça que cette foi en lui
elle vous adore 1
j'ai découvert ça à ce moment là oui
mais non en fait il veut d'abord anne
aymone giscard d'estaing que vous adorez
oui parce que je me suis occupé de
prédation j'ai envoyé jusqu'à 250
enfants vous été formulée parce qu'il
veut des enfants qui voulez vous pouvez
nous envoyer des enfants un peu plus
canal
est formidable pierre cardo il est il
une député iba michel rocard il arrive à
l'assemblée il dit quoi le premier truc
et hautbois peut-être baissé nos
traitements qu'ils ont regardé
ce type c'est ce que j'ai fait en
arrivant à la mairie quand je serai pas
d'argent mais vous êtes commence par
nous parce que sinon on va se faire tuer
mais c'est un il faut savoir que si on
le chef c'est lui qui est devant mais
qui montrent l'exemple c'est pas celui
qui est derrière est donc si vous
montrez l'exemple ça passe mieux que si
vous expliquer aux autres ce qu'ils
doivent faire les devoirs c'est pour
vous les droits c'est pour ça va pas
pourquoi vous n'avez pas pourquoi vous
n'avez pas voulu aller plus loin
plus loin que quoi ni au niveau national
au niveau politique m'engage à ce que
moi j'ai pas fait porte lorsque la
première fois qu'on s'est rencontrés
c'est lorsque je co présidait la
commission quartiers populaires pour la
fondation terra nova à l'époque et on a
été impressionnés mais impressionné et
d'ailleurs
j'étais ravi que vous soyez venu parce
que ça faisait quelques temps je me
battais avec jacques donzelot pour lui
faire comprendre ce qui se passe
réellement sur le kart sur le terrain et
je me suis dit on a besoin de personnes
comme ça pour pour pour aller plus loin
en politique ça soit ministrable premier
ministrable et voire même présent la
république pourquoi vous avez pas voulu
plus vous vous engagez au fait je n'aime
pas les partis politiques j'ai toujours
eu du mal à me faire je n'ai jamais trop
fréquenter les instances un petit j'en
ai été souvent très proches je pense que
je ne suis pas fait pour ça ou alors
enfin ça aurait tellement décoiffé je
suis pas sûr que j'ai eu
l'énergie soit peut fermer sa gueule
je pense que si on m'avait j'ai pensé
oui du temps où simone veil penser
effectivement il voit la cie balladur
avait gagné j'étais ministre et puis
après coup je me suis dit mais
finalement est ce que réellement
je peux tenir longtemps dans un
gouvernement non parce que je ne
pourrais pas fermer ma gueule à un
moment donné je vais pas être d'accord
et je vais le dire donc je vais faire
trois mois et puis je vais me faire
virer où je vais démissionner donc si
c'est pour faire ça c'est pas la peine
j'ai eu beaucoup de discussions avec des
collègues de ma famille politique ou
autre qui avait été ministre ou qui
était ministre ce qu'on leur impose ça
ne
l'est pas avec moi à un moment donné je
vais sortir une grosse connerie parce
que je pense que j'ai raison et j'ai
tort de le faire en tant que ministre ça
ferme sa gueule comme disait chevènement
où ça tient ou ça démissionne
aujourd'hui de très bonne idée parce que
les méthodes que je j'ai utilisé à
chanteloup pour essayer de réussir ce
pari qui avait je suis pas persuadé
qu'au niveau national
je préférerais donner des conseils à des
gens qui ont envie de mettre en place
des politiques de la ville et les
conseiller sur ce qu'il faut faire ou
pas faire les accompagner essayer de
faire en sorte que que les gens
comprennent un peu c'est quoi à l'esprit
la pretty la ville mais être ministre
non quand je vois la façon dont les
débats zappa l'enfant à la santé et
comment les ministres perdent leur temps
à des débats sempiternel selon les
procédures je me dis non mais j'ai pas
que ça à faire quoi gcc pouvant table
d'être ministre un mot pour terminer
parce que élèves locaux lorsqu'ils
douloureusement mais quand vous regardez
chanteloup aujourd'hui vous revenez
pour vous reconnaissez champ clos
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire encore
quoi
ça a beaucoup changé quand même il n'y a
qu'une chose qu'il faut faire c'est il
faut toujours qu'il se passe quelque
chose sur un quartier c'est quand il ne
se passe rien de ça devient très
dangereux donc il faut de la vie il faut
des animations faut que les gens
s'amusent c'est beaucoup plus important
qu'on ne le pense bien sûr il faut des
réussie dans le domaine de l'
architecture du développement économique
là mais il faut le lien social il faut
que les gens s'aiment entre eux il faut
qu'ils apprennent à vivre ensemble à
vivre des événements semble donc ça
passe par des petites choses mais le
café que j'ai pris ce matin avec les
dames du centre social avec les équipes
etc mais ce sont des moments importants
ces moments de convivialité mais on
n'imagine pas à quel point c'est
essentiel dans une société qui sait
déshumanisé comment est ce que vous
pouvez penser vous appartenez à ce pays
et à cette république et la respecter si
vous avez l'impression d'être mis à
l'écart parce que les services publics
sont plus là en tout petit bon ici on en
a maintenu catherine s'est battu pour
avoir un certain nombre de choses mais
c'est vrai que ça c'est déshumanisé avec
en plus la fracture numérique mais vous
imaginez l'isolément des gens c'est
épouvantable le maire en plus il ya de
moins en moins de pouvoir sur le
territoire donc que l'on s'adresse à lui
mais c'est pas lui qui peut régler le
problème ça fait beaucoup de choses et
donc
le il faut continuer à faire des choses
il faut surprendre il faut pas hésiter à
prendre des risques et le problème du
politique aujourd'hui et notamment à un
haut niveau c'est que la bête politique
c'est une bête frileuse mais qui peut
être dangereuse aussi donc mais elle est
d'abord frileuse elle aime à prendre des
risques est par contre si on se pose à
elle et que ça se passe pas bien
elle peut être méchante donc faut le
savoir et la politique c'est un combat
permanent combat pour les autres et
qu'on bat aussi pour sa survie
juan un mot et surtout quand vous
revenez comme ça baheux
concernant chanteloup c'est un petit peu
la règle
comtois on devrais je ne sais pas en
tout cas je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut
faire mais je sais ce qu'il ne faut pas
fait et ce qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est
en tout cas ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
d'arriver à une
conclusion très simple on est nombreux
mais seul
c'est l'individualisme l'individualisme
est ce qui a tenu cette ville justement
c'est le fait que les pierre cardo et
toute son équipe et le tissu associatif
est passé son temps à faire en sorte que
les les traits d'union entre les
communautés les traits d'union entre les
générations
soit possible et visible c'est à dire il
ya eu il ya le le bien faire et bien
bien montré et ici ce qui nous a un
moment sauver c'est ce sentiment que
quelles que soient nos origines quelles
que soient nos communautés nos
générations on était chante louvain et
ça nous a sauvé parce que dans un pays
où être français c'est très compliqué
c'est très dur d'être français gens
disent oui il faut s'intégrer mais ça ne
dépend pas uniquement de vous ça dépend
aussi de votre de l'environnement de ce
qui vous regarde et au moins si on avait
du mal à avoir ce sentiment d'être
français à part entière on savait qu'on
était chantelouve est à 200% et ça ça
nous a ça a permis de combler un vide
c'est le vent voilà merci infiniment
merci
merci merci pour ce moment
essentiel évidemment c'est l'éducation
absolument le fond monde pouvait qu'avec
les sites et éducatives l'ailé les les
expériences qu'il faut il des choses
absolument formidable qu'il faut que des
écolos rab et qu'on a ici
enfin on a perdu quand même de
nombreuses années au niveau national
pour en arriver à défendre ce principe
de cité éducative chez nous c'est des
principes à une époque voilà on en
parlait déjà il ya 25 ans mais il aura
fallu tout ce temps là pour commencer à
arriver à mettre en place le processus
merci cole ne peut pas il seul et regret
prennent leur éducation et tout ce qu'il
a confié une mission précise merci
beaucoup merci les rssi ce bien
[Musique]